[Music]
hey it's clueless gamer with Conan
O'Brien and today we're talking about
Michael Phelps push the limit I don't
know much about video games in fact I'll
be honest I know nothing but the joy of
this experience is that I will ask the
questions that a complete novice would
ask which in its own way will be a kind
of beautiful truth here to help me is my
friend in all things web and Internet
Erin Blair hey Erin
that's a cool device that you're gonna
use to start the game what is it it's a
Nokia Lumia nokia lumia rolls off the
tongue I hear those are really cool
they're awesome and pause the game
perfect we're gonna pick our swimmer
whatever swimmer you want to be so I
don't want to be Phelps that's too
obvious too obvious okay we've got this
guy nope don't want to be him okay I
want someone whose body is better than
mine and so far these are just as good
or inferior I have a better body than
him I'll be her I'm gonna be the girl oh
okay perfect
I'll be Michael Phelps yeah you be
Phelps okay and start it okay what's
your favorite Olympic sport I got to go
at the track and field's it's just fun
to watch it's exciting
I also the one where they ski and then
shoot the rifle oh my Athlon that's cool
that's awesome yeah that's the most
useful of all though right I don't think
so
when have you ever had to hunt someone
down an escaped criminal on skis never
all right so this is an event that's
being played that's helped a skyscraper
when we start we're gonna go like this
to amp up the crowd get them on our side
I pull up it's we're gonna start doing
on the show yeah they suck there's a
gauge you want to get it in the middle
of the blue wow you're doing really well
I suppose yeah
quiet great swimming oh now do it as
fast as you can
I'm not sure I understand what's wrong
about what I'm doing
ourselves tonight who won I won what did
you win yes I don't know you know why
because you're a guy and the whole
system is rigged against us women just
the better swimmer you weren't a better
swimmer we both did the exact same
flailing around and my character was
actually right there with your character
and then the game decides let's give it
to the dude it's called Michael Phelps
and you chose me Michael Phelps and I
chose to be a woman and then guess who
wins that's my first criticism with this
game I think Phelps always wins let's do
a relay
we'll be on the same team how does that
sound whatever we're gonna don't do this
you look so stupid oh I went oh what
happened here double start I didn't do
anything wrong
yes - Ivan too fast too fast thing is
swimming is it bad yeah isn't that the
point of being in the Atlanta I don't
know what coach yells at an Olympic
player you're swimming too fast reach
now too late it's got too late what
everything I do is not right by this
machine it's also showing chlorine
levels in the pool which i think is
fascinating that's an unnecessary
addition to the game why do you need to
have chlorine levels it also now is
showing urine levels good job bleh
sorry nervous reach now
we lost yep yep you know why look woman
this game is sexist Michael Phelps push
it to the limit what do you think if
you're playing the game try and be
Phelps if you can't be Phelps be it dude
if you're a woman you might as well not
play out of 44 stars 35 being great 11
being not so good to being really good 1
being horrible I'd give this about a 15
and a half it's a complicated scale and
I know we're gonna get complaints about
it but I honestly believe it's the best
system louis gamer killer o'brien see
you guys next time yeah yeah that's
sorry are you gonna be here next time if
that's ok with you all right you're
having a small heart attack you need to
go that I'll sit down